[Music]
foreign
then for the Press preview it's our
first look at what is on tomorrow's
front pages and checking out the
headlines tonight political editor at
the sun Harry Cole and the political
editor at the guardian pipette Carrera
they'll be with us from now until just
before midnight very good evening to you
so much to talk about before we do that
let's have a look at the front pages for
you beginning with the Metro the ax man
cometh that's how they see the arrival
of Jeremy Hunter's Chancellor with Liz
trust his economic policies and maybe
even her career facing the chop
the guardian pictures them together on
the commons front bench with the
headline hunt rips up PM's plans in
astounding you turn on tax
while the financial times says the prime
minister's future is on a knife edge
after her entire economic strategy was
ripped up
the other big Financial paper City am
shows a grave marking the death of
so-called trasonomics and the
inscription May markets rest in peace
while Harry's paper the sun describes
her as the ghost PM over the way she
appeared in the Commons for the U-turn
announcements according to the I Jeremy
Hunt is now in charge and mistras is
fearing a possible exit
The Mirror Has one word for it Liz truss
has been humiliated
the star which is already labeled her a
wet lettuce pictures her in hospital and
says she's now on Leaf supports
the express quotes her from her latest
interview tonight I'm sorry we went too
far and too fast
the telegraph quotes Jeremy Hunt's
Commons statement with the ominous words
we must take decisions of eye-watering
difficulty
so don't forget you can scan the QR code
on screen now and check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch us discussing them and I'm joined
tonight by Harry Cole and Pippa Pereira
not hiding under their desks but sat at
their desks in front of their cameras uh
what a remarkable day it's been Jeremy
Hunter's shredded trustonomics but he
went even further than a straightforward
U-turn tonight the Prime Minister
apologizing for mistakes the front of
the eye Pippa hunt takes charge as PM
fears the exit that headline pretty much
summing things up
it does today that's right Jonathan and
of course really Liz trust handed over
power to Jeremy Hunt on Friday when she
pointed in Chancellor having sacked
quasi-kartang
um he was the sacrifice that needed to
be made in order for her to survive
um and the so the next step in her
survival was pointing somebody that
could with reissue the markets and
conservative MPS
um that the government's economic
strategy was one which wasn't going to
lead to
um to a major crisis uh so ultimately
when they met at Checkers yesterday uh
Liz truss and Jeremy Hunt he went
through line by line her mini budget and
of course we'd already heard the
reversal of the 45p top rate of tax on
Friday they announced the reversal of
the corporation tax
and policy
um and uh they went through the I'm told
that they went through the the remaining
uh parts of the mini budget line by line
and uh in uncertain times Jeremy Hunt
had to make clear to list trust and she
agreed that in order to get everything
back on track he was going to have to
rip up the rest of it we were expecting
the overnight the 1p uh basically it's
an income tax possibly delayed a year
and then we found out this morning from
Jeremy Hunt that of course it has been
suspended entirely and then the big one
really because it was the last piece of
the last piece last weapon in her Armory
was the um the scaling back of the
energy the energy support package uh for
households that was due to last up into
the next election in a couple of years
time but now he's been scaled back to
just six months time and then they'll
review it so it's quite clearly
um the case that that Hunters grabbed
control of the levers of power and is is
pushes is buried this trusses economic
strategy and uh is pushing ahead with
really quite serious changes both in
terms of the mini budget but also in
terms of cutting spending across
departments in the days ahead he's very
much tonight The Man In Charge yeah and
the big question of course is um has she
bought herself more time by appointing
Jeremy Hunt to make these decisions and
this statement today or are her day's
numbers the front of your paper Harry
the ghost PM because her performance
today was very strange wasn't it
yeah it was frankly weird
um she sat there almost emotionless a
blink or two as everything she promised
the country and the Tory party
membership all summer was shredded in
front of her
um and didn't so much as Flinch as that
happened now uh let's trust throughout
her career as someone that's made a big
play of her ideological commitments uh
the sort of strand of free market
terrorism that runs through her body she
clearly spent many years sitting on the
on the sort of cabinet sideline so to
speak of and what working out and
watching what she would do if she had
the levers of power now she's come in
she's pulled those levers it's all gone
wrong and that's gone out the window I
think the it's clear tonight that the
Instinct of survival
is far stronger than any ideological
bone that Liz trust has in their body
now you could argue of what is the point
of staying in power if everything you
wanted to do anyway
um is now being sort of shredded uh I
don't think it's so much Jeremy Hunt
taking control but it's the treasury
they have clearly told him exactly what
needs to be done and he is not pushed
back on any of it it is a phenomenal
about turn and yes I think Liz truss has
probably bought herself some more time
there's a sort of febrile atmosphere
that's felt a bit deflated actually
tonight the the plot is realizing that
no one really has a candidate to replace
so no one has a mechanism to replace her
um yet
um and I think they're going to limp on
you know mortally wounded and uh looking
at an opposition that are totally Cocker
hoop yeah well let's talk more about
that then because uh Pippa at one stage
today we were told that she had a
meeting with sagran Brady uh from the
1922 Committee of that benches of course
it was a vital me eating so important
she had to go to it rather than go to uh
the commons do we know any more about
that meeting and also do we know any
more about the meeting that she had
tonight with the the one nation group um
and of course she's meeting the ERG
tomorrow what are they all saying to her
well Harry it's a very accurate picture
of the scenes in the Commons when Liz
truss eventually arrived and sat next to
Jeremy Hunters he as he tore up her
agenda but just before then Libra had
tabled or been granted an urgent
question which basically means an
opportunity for
um them to to ask an individual minister
in this case they wanted the Prime
Minister about a specific issue and they
had we used political tool really but
they had used this in order to put
pressure on this trust to appear for the
commons because nobody had seen her
publicly since that really humiliating
moment on Friday at a press conference
when she had to accept that she had she
had to sacked quasiquartering and
ditched half of her policy so um the
tactic to embarrass her I suppose worked
um but there was a huge amount of
speculation going on in the comments
when Penny moordant who Penny mordant
who of course was one of her Rivals for
the leadership uh stood in in her place
to to respond on the government's behalf
and kept saying when people were asking
where is Liz truss who actually probably
wouldn't expect to be there as
conventional really for them for the
Prime Minister not to appear at these
things these days they send a minister
in their stead
um but penny board and repeatedly asked
by labor MPS came up with a whole series
of answers so she's got very serious
reasons she's got very genuine reasons
for not to be here
um I can't tell you what they are can't
divulge them but they are very genuine
um a bizarre side about her not being
under a desk
um but uh ultimately she sort of hyped
up this this view in the comments that
something was up had you know had had
trust disappeared off to Ukraine was
there something wrong was she in fact
learning that uh enough Victorian peas
had um submitted letters to lead the
process of starting to ice her and then
I was told that in fact she was in a
meeting with graham Brady who is the
chair of the back bench 1922 committee
and of course even though the rules
states that she can't be have another
confidence vote within a year we all
know that the rules can be disbanded if
there's enough support for that within
the conservative party quite a threshold
high threshold of about two-thirds of
MPS I think so of course that then set
up a whole another range of speculation
but I was also told that this meeting
was in fact a pre-planned one he
obviously speaks to her and meets with
her regularly it wasn't a sort of Crisis
talks in which he was delivering her a
terrible message about impending woe or
Doom but it is inevitable number 10
sources admitted to me that in that
meeting he will have raised the scale of
concern that exists within the
conservative party I don't think it's
yet at the point where she's about to be
ousted I think Harry's right there's a
big question mark around who would take
over from her and I think there's a sort
of a feeling amongst MPS they need to at
least give them until the Halloween
budget and they'll be our forecast to
see what that brings but she's in really
she really is in sort of very very
dangerous territory
um and uh there's not much standing in
the way between her and power and her
MPS pushing her out yeah I think we're
going to see lots of Halloween analogies
aren't we over the next few days we've
had uh the ghost pm on the front of the
sun let's have a look at the front of
the city am trusonomics a gravestone
there September 22 to October 22 late to
rest by Jeremy Hunt May markets rest in
peace and and that's actually what they
have done today the markets have
um certainly been a bit calmer haven't
they Harry
yeah well this is what this was entirely
designed to do this was why Jeremy Hunt
was up early on the uh you know
announcing the announcement before the
markets had opened they rushed It
Forward rather than waiting for this
afternoon to to do it and I think it was
a pretty bold comprehensive offer to the
markets it was however a bold sort of
move to someone else who was paying very
close attention to this which is the
office of budget responsibility now the
the sort of u-turns and screeching sort
of chaos was seen in the last 10 days
all began about a week last Friday when
the obr gave their first sort of draft
forecast of the state of the nation's
finances to to Liz truss and then chance
the Quasi quaten and which highlighted
the fact that far from there being a 30
billion back hole which we suspected
there might be in their numbers is
actually 72 billion that's when you
started to see things really move
quickly the chance to get fired and and
Trust bringing hunt and and the sort of
treasuries there's a warning that
um that uh you know that Halloween uh
obr forecast is going to be dire now
crucially it doesn't necessarily matter
about what the obr say other than you
know it's survivable the criticism of
the day about what the crucial thing was
though is on the 3rd of November
interest rates are going to go up again
the bank of England is going to make
that decision no one's expected them to
stay where they are it's the scale of
what mortgage repayments are going to
have to go up by that's really worrying
people now the thought is if you can get
ahead of the obr you can get that 72
billion pound uh figure down and they've
made 32 billion pound dent in it today
by Jefferson all of trusses all of
trusses uh uh tax cutting there's still
a very large 40 billion pound hole in
that that's going to come have to come
from savings cuts to you and me or
indeed further tax Rises so hopefully I
think the plan is to avoid fingers
crossed rates rise Beyond something that
is culpable you know to some degree
rather than a shock big rise on the 3rd
of November okay um fascinating stuff
we're gonna have to leave it there uh
stay with us coming up after the break
the latest characterization leading to
criticism in the hit series The Crown
discussing that and more in a moment
[Music]
welcome back part two of The Press
preview Harry and Pippa still with me uh
Pippa inside the Metro uh climate
activists have been busy recently
haven't they and uh problems on the M25
today
yeah so the M25 today I think over the
weekend there was an incident in
Knightsbridge that far Cruz couldn't get
through a junction and of course we've
seen multiple incidents in recent um in
recent weeks of uh just stop oil or
extension Rebellion activists protesting
against the new oil and gas licenses
which have been granted which are being
granted by the government
um and uh doing this by sort of you know
shutting down shutting down roads and
commuters routes to work and uh so a
brieferman spoke about this it was
yesterday talking about how she's going
to bring in the public order bill which
would stop in her words uh protesters
holding people to Ransom protesters
themselves are responding saying that
they're raising a really important issue
they're doing into non-violent way and
we live in a free country I suspect this
is not the last of this that we've heard
yeah Harry have you got an issue with
this I mean we've seen all sorts of
things this week haven't we pouring milk
in supermarkets spraying and Aston
Martin showroom there was the the soup
over the sunflowers the van Gogh as well
yeah well I hope they'd go down for that
one that was that was utterly absurd
well I find is ridiculous why have they
shut the road they look fine up there if
they want to climb the the qut bridge
let them but I don't know why everyone
else should be inconvenienced for their
Ridiculousness um leave them up there
okay Essex police say uh this is a
complex operation due to the height at
which the protesters are situated
obviously a struggle to to get them down
and let's finish with this story on the
front of the Daily Telegraph paper I
don't know if you're a fan of the crown
uh series five of the Netflix drama and
there's anger over the portrayal of uh
Countess mountbatten although it doesn't
say who's angry I guess you've got to
read inside to find out who is so
annoyed about this I mean the program's
not even been out yet
no well I'm a fan of the ones that we've
had to date and this this series was
always going to run into trouble because
it came up close to the modern day so
it's affecting
um you know the royal family in our
lifetimes rather than sort of more
historically
um and you've really had John Major for
example coming out and criticizing a
plotline about Prince Charles trying to
encourage him to get the queen to
abdicate
um the latest I think is that uh that uh
what was her name countessman baton who
was a friend of Prince Phillips the sub
suggestion about their relationship was
closer than it maybe should have been
Diana and Charles
um spitting up is a factor is a is a um
a key part of this series it's obviously
good to ruffle feathers particularly
coming so quickly after the The Queen's
death and last year of Prince Philip's
death
um royalists are not impressed by it uh
but the but Netflix The Producers say
that it is just fiction Prince Harry
said last year he was quite relaxed
about it says it's sort of like roughly
right and it is just Fiction it's
dramatization yeah and people should get
to tag up on the details